Speaker 2: Real quick, a fact, this is
just like a small little side thing,
but I found that interesting. Fox News host
Jesse WATTERS was confused by the existence
of Hispanic and Latin American Jews, and he
genuinely is visibly confused. It's you know.
Speaker 1: What? It would.
Speaker 2: Be nice if these
people knew something about anything.
Speaker 5: Down there. And he totally blows
it because he was at a hearing. You remember Ted
Cruz asked him and you guys got weeks to prepare
for the hearing. That's all they do is prepare
for hearings. And he goes, You have many people
that cross the border now. Do you have any kids
that are in your cages now? Do you even know if
Joe Biden or Kamala Harris went to the border in
2021? No, he couldn't answer. He couldn't answer
anything. Now, he was probably nominated the
least. That's the what they tout is because he
was Hispanic, he was born in Cuba. His parents are
Jewish, which was confusing to me. But, you know,
I don't know a lot about about that stuff.
Speaker 2: Yeah, no, we can tell. You don't
know much about that. And again, it just this
is not like a that exotic or bizarre of a thing.
There are plenty of Jews in Central and South
America. I'm Jewish, I'm from Argentina, plenty of
Jews in Argentina. Jews have lived in Cuba for a
very long time. There are some Cubans who actually
their Jewish ancestry goes back to. There's a
weird term, but crypto Jews, Jews who were fleeing
the Spanish Inquisition and lived as non-Jews but
were actually Jewish. And there has been Jewish
emigration to Cuba, you know, between 1919 50 and
many, many countries in Latin America with not
insignificant Jewish populations. Argentina
at the top of the list with about 180,000
Jews as of eight years ago. These numbers have
changed. Brazil has close to 100,000 Jews, Mexico,
40,000, etc., etc.. This is you know, it would
be nice if I'm not saying this is the standard
by which we judge whether people know anything. I
don't know much about Jews in Latin America, but
it would be nice if just the reality of the world
weren't so confusing to Fox News hosts and to
these right wingers who are so confident in their
opinions about everything. But they just know so
little about everything as well. Disappointing I
think maybe is the term I would apply. Let me know
your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Quick break. Great Friday show for you today.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, a
community supported program. You are part
of that community and I would love for you to sign
up and show your support. Pledge your support at
Join Packman ICOM. You can use the coupon code
a big voting 22. A reminder about how important
what we have coming up in early November is
voting yes. And of course, you'll get all
the member benefits no matter what discount you
get, including the daily bonus show, commercial
free audio and video streams of the show members,
only town hall events and many, many other things